hi my name's fedsim I'm a singer a
musician and I live in Berlin
thirty nine-year-old Fitz and savart
lived in Stuttgart for most of his
childhood his family originally came
from Northeast Africa my parents came
from Eritrea here on the Horn of Africa
then because of the war they moved to
Egypt where I was born then we moved
from Egypt to Italy and then we ended up
leaving for Germany
faites amin in berlin since 2004 his
parents fought in the Eritrean war of
independence from Ethiopia in 1976 his
mother was injured and flown out to
Cairo
then came years of wandering that
eventually led to Germany fits-him sang
about his family's past on his 2012
debut album the colors of hope
it was important for me to process a few
things my birth in Cairo the long road
to Rome and then Germany when I see what
others who travel the same Road at the
same time still have to struggle with I
see myself as a builder of bridges a
translator and a mediator that's what
I'd like to be with my music medicine
grow up with pop soul and breguet and
with Eritrean revolutionary songs and
Italian ballads as a young boy he
thought of his refugee past as a great
adventurer later he started asking
questions
I got reactions from other people when
playing soccer and so on all kinds of
things tell you that apparently you're
not from here and you ask your parents
what are we actually doing here fits and
started rapping in 2006 instructors
active hip-hop scene
many of his musical mentors came from
the United States - my first hip-hop CDs
were by eazy-e and Run DMC black
performers with new stuff that had an
edge and made a statement even if I
didn't understand at all I knew it made
a statement and that was interesting
because I was 12 or 13 and I was
realizing I look different me a club
okay he said another hours looking
different was enough reason for the
far-right terrorists of the National
Socialist Union to kill ten people in
Germany between 2000 and 2007 nine were
immigrants alleged accomplice and sole
survivor being outed shaper has been on
trial since May 2013 the investigation
was often botched and the motives
overlooked I think it's insane that it
was even possible in Germany it took
eight years to find them and the way the
authorities treated the victims
for example telling a kebab stand owners
parents that their son had probably been
in some mafia dispute it wasn't even
conjecture who is just an outright lie
black Olivia
Phet Sims creative response is music
music can bring people together you're
on stage and the house lights go on and
you see all the different people there
who might never brush shoulders with
each other outside but here their arm
and arm is singing along and enjoying
the same good feeling then you know
you're doing something right that's most
astute last year in London Berlin and
Los Angeles fits-him wrote the songs for
his second album it's due out this year